you
[Applause]
if we traveled back to the year 800 BC
in Greece we would see that merchants
whose business has failed were forced to
sit in the marketplace with a basket
over their heads in pre-modern Italy
failed business owners who had
outstanding vets were taken totally
naked to the public square where they
have to bank their box against a special
stone while a crowd cheered at them in
the 17th century in France failed
business owners were taken to the center
of the market where the beginning of
their bankruptcy was publicly announced
and in order to avoid immediate
imprisonment they have to wear a green
bonnet so that everyone knew they were a
failure of course these are extreme
examples but it is important to remember
then when we excessively punish those
who fail with stifle innovation and
business creation the engines of
economic growth in any country time has
passed and today we don't publicly
humiliate failed entrepreneurs and they
don't broadcast their failures on social
media
in fact I think that all of us can
relate with the pain of failure but we
don't share the details of those
experiences and I totally get it my
friends I have also been there I had a
business that fail and sharing that
story was incredibly hard
in fact it required seven years a good
dose of vulnerability and the company of
my friends this is my failure story when
I was in college studying business I met
a group of indigenous women they lived
in a poor rural community in the state
of Puebla in central Mexico they made
beautiful handmade products and when I
met them and I saw their work I decided
I wanted to help with some friends I
co-founded a social enterprise with the
mission to help the women create an
income stream and
improve their quality of life we did
everything by the book
as we have learned in business school we
got investors we spent a lot of time
building the business and training the
women but soon we realized we were
novices the handmade products were not
selling and the financial plan we have
made was totally unrealistic
in fact we worked for years without a
salary hoping that a miracle would
happen that magically a great buyer
would arrive and she would make the
business profitable but that miracle
never happened in the end we have to
close the business and that broke my
heart
I started everything to create a
positive impact on the life of the
artisans and I felt that I have done the
opposite I felt so guilty that I decided
to hide this failure from my
conversations and my resume for years I
didn't know other faith entrepreneurs
and I thought I was the only loser in
the world one night seven years later I
was out with some friends and we were
talking about the life of the
entrepreneur and of course the issue of
failure came out I decided to confess my
friends the story of my failed business
and they shared similar stories in that
moment I thought became really clear in
my mind all of my friends were failures
being more serious that night I realized
that a I wasn't the only loser in the
world and B we all have hidden failures
please tell me if that is not true that
night was like an exorcism for me I
realized that sharing your failures
makes you stronger not weaker and being
open to my vulnerability helped me
connect with others in
deeper and more meaningful way and
embrace life lessons I wouldn't have
learned previously as a consequence of
this experience of sharing a stories of
businesses that didn't work we decided
to create a platform of events to help
others share their failure stories and
we called it up nights years later
we also created a research center
devoted to the study of failure and its
implications on business people and
society and as we loved cool names we
called it the failure Institute it has
been surprising to see that when an
entrepreneur stands on a stage and
shares a story of failure she can
actually enjoy that experience it
doesn't have to be a moment of shame and
embarrassment as it used to be in the
past it is an opportunity to share
lessons learned and build empathy we
have also discovered that when the
members of a team shared their failures
magic happens
bonds grow stronger and collaboration
becomes easier through our events and
research projects we have found some
interesting facts for instance that men
and women react in a different way after
the failure of a business the most
common reaction among men is to start a
new business within one year of failure
but in a different sector while women
decide to look for a job and postpone
the creation of a new business our
hypothesis is that this happens because
women tends to suffer more from the
imposter syndrome we feel that we need
something else to be a good entrepreneur
but I have seen that in many many cases
women have everything that's needed we
just need to take the step and in the
case of man it is more common to see
that they feel they have enough
knowledge and just need to put it in
practice in another place with better
luck another interesting finding has
been that there are regional differences
on how entrepreneurs
cope with failure for instance the most
common reaction after the failure of a
business in the American continent is to
go back to school well in Europe the
most common reaction is to look for a
therapist we're not sure which is a
better reaction after the failure of a
business but this is something we will
study in the future
another interesting finding have been
the profound impact that public policy
hasn't failed entrepreneurs for instance
in my country in Mexico the regulatory
environment is so hard that closing a
business can take you a lot of time and
a lot of money let's begin with the
money in the best possible scenario
meaning you know you don't have problems
with partners providers clients
employees in the best possible scenario
closing officially a business will cost
you $2,000 which is a lot of money in
Mexico someone who earns the minimum
wage would have to work for 15 months to
save this amount now let's talk about
the time as you may know in most of the
developing world the average life
expectancy of a business is two years in
Mexico the process of officially closing
a business takes two years what happens
when the average life expectancy of a
business is so similar to the time it
will take you to close it if it doesn't
work of course this discourages business
creation and promotes informal economy
in fact econometric research has proved
that if the process of declaring
bankruptcy takes less time and less
money more new firms will enter the
market for this reason in 2017 we
proposed a series of public policy
recommendations for the procedure of
officially closing businesses in Mexico
for a whole year we worked with
entrepreneurs from all over the country
and with Congress and the good news is
that women
helped change the law the idea is that
when the new regulation comes into force
entrepreneurs will be able to close
their businesses in an online procedure
that is faster and inexpensive on the
night we invented up nights we
never imagined that the movement would
grow this big we are in 80 countries now
in that moment our only intention was to
put the topic of failure on the table to
help our friends see that failure is
something we must talk about it is not a
cause of humiliation as it used to be in
the past
or a course of celebration as some
people say in fact I want to confess
something every time I listen to Silicon
Valley types or students bragging about
failing fast and often like it's no big
deal
I cringe because I think that there is a
dark side on the mantra fail fast
of course failing fast is a great way to
accelerate learning and avoid wasting
time but I fear that when we present
rapid failure to entrepreneurs as their
one and only option we might be
promoting laziness we might be promoting
that entrepreneurs give up too easily I
also fear that the culture of rapid
failure could be minimizing the
devastating consequences of the failure
of a business for instance when my
social enterprise died the worst part
was that I have to go back to the
indigenous community and tell the women
that the business had failed and it was
my fault for some people this could be
seen like a great learning opportunity
for me but the truth is that the closure
of this business represented much more
than that it meant that the women would
stop receiving an income that they
really needed for this reason I want to
propose something
I want to propose that just as we put
aside the idea of publicly humiliating
failed entrepreneurs we must put aside
the idea that failing fast is always the
best and I want to propose a new mantra
fail mindfully we must remember that
businesses are made of people businesses
are not entities that appear and
disappear magically without consequences
when a firm dies some people will lose
their jobs and others will lose their
money and in the case of social and
green enterprises the death of this
business can have a negative impact on
the ecosystems or communities they were
trying to serve but what does it mean to
fail mindfully it means being aware of
the impact of the consequences of the
failure of that business being aware of
the lessons learned and being aware of
their responsibility to share those
learnings with the world thank you
[Applause]